bitcoin is looking a little calmer today
but the question is when
will the roller coaster ride continue
again two months ago the cryptocurrency
was worth
nearly 65 000
now it's trading at below 40
000. that is basically 40 percent
less than where it was trading in
mid-april critics say
it's speculation and investors should
stay away especially because of that
volatility
well the virtual currency has been on a
wild ride
it's more recent highs and lows though
subject to the whims of
entrepreneur elon musk whose support or
criticism of bitcoin can drive up the
price
or send a tumbling let's bring in
economist
maurice hufkin who says bitcoin is
the digital version of gold only worse
why why is that because i thought gold
was a pretty safe investment
maurice well well thanks for having me
on the show
um that is because bitcoin is
scarce and it is a scarce commodity
and scarcity means that it is fixed in
its supply and
that is not a good characteristic for
money because
everything that is cars can become quite
volatile
which as you mentioned is definitely the
case for bitcoin you mentioned the
roller coaster right
and um well that that might be of
interest for investors but
that doesn't add value to the real
economy because if the price is
quite volatile then investors don't know
and especially firms don't know when to
invest and
i also think that bitcoiners have a
false or faulty theory of money
behind the whole project since they see
inflation
moderate inflation as a risk and they
think that
deflation is a good thing for the
economy which is uh
definitely not the case the fact is
though that more and more companies
uh starting to use bitcoin as a means of
payment el salvador
has even recognized it as the official
currency
it sounds like it's set to become a
global
currency whether or not those criticisms
of yours
have have some sort of basis
well first of all el salvador is a very
very small country
and uh they just do it i think for
financial inclusion reasons uh
which is okay but i don't think that
developed countries will start to accept
the bitcoin as um
as official currency um because
well that would be highly problematic
because if money is scarce
and taxes are not only paid in the
real currency such as the euro or the us
dollar but also in bitcoin
then um the countries do constrain their
spending capacity
and that isn't a good thing for for
country to
to to do now maurice uh besides
bitcoin's financial
instability a lot of us know that mining
the virtual currency eats up a lot of
energy
but what do you think of the efforts to
improve its carbon footprint with
clean electricity
well as long as we do have bitcoin as a
speculative object i think it's a good
thing to do
because i think it uses the same amount
of electricity
at the moment such as argentina so the
whole country
um so very wasteful but um
overall i don't think that the
blockchain
technology which is good in itself it's
a good technological innovation
um is necessary for
a currency because um the decentralized
and
anonymous process isn't a very isn't a
characteristic that money or currency
needs
maurice give us your take again where do
you reckon bitcoin is going to be
in the next five years i know it's a big
question i want to add
tough to say well there's a whole card
around bitcoin and
well it can go even higher in its price
especially if elon musk comes comes back
on the show again
but well it can also go
go the other way and uh fall quite low
in its price
and i think over the over the long term
bitcoin
will fail because of its uh
faulty characteristics or uh
construction
and yeah so my my bet is it won't become
an official currency and it won't
play a big role in the years to come
hey economist maurice hofkin there thank
you very much for being on the show good
to talk to you
thanks a lot
you